hi the purpose of this film is for
aikidoka
or
it could be for
yogis
i could even extend it to
uh tai chi
people
or
let's just say any activity martial art
that is carried out in the world
perhaps even cycling
running sports
yes let's dedicate this to anybody who
needs to use their breath
because
i could oh
even though these were my main films and
what i talk about
because that's the subject and um
especially on facebook
four and a half thousand members now
friends that
i have
they mainly want to know about aikido
i'm hoping that um
not only you but everybody will want to
know about uh
how to
have better health
how to do the best you can with your
your health
we're breathing all the time
but
if you want to become more efficient and
use the breath as a benefit
they say
that you need it in piranha in yoga
in tai chi
it's classed as a section
under qikon
in aikido it's called cochu
um
in the
old
films on the television
in the
armed forces
the sergeant major would go up in front
of the
long line of new recruits
puff his chest out and say
come on you lazy
people so
this reminds me really of how
puffing the chest out
in this way
in a military way
is really about
calling forth your best power
going to the other end of the scale in
yoga where
you're doing very calm
asideness
poses that is
you never make calmness
and you're using the breath in a gentle
way
in a rhythmic way
not demanding too much breath in
but being aware of it being conscious of
it
so having done yoga now from
more years than i can remember
let's guess around about 40.
i've realized that the passiveness of
breathing
can really be refreshing
so i'm encouraging you here in this film
to
not just listen to me but search out
youtube
and find breathing exercises and the
benefits of breathing and why so many um
think that it's a value
it's like having a bar of gold it's like
winning the lottery
if you can make it more efficient within
your body
then you can use it to benefit your
your health your well-being
and if you're in a martial art it
doesn't matter what martial arts
but if it's a plot point where you need
instant power
not ego
not strength
not the mind saying i want to destroy
i want to create
ultimate power so i win
yes it could be used for that but like
anything in yin and yang there's a good
and there's a bad
and sometimes you have to mix the two
together i'm trying to talk about the
good
the breath for the good
in my patreon site where
i have people from across the world
joining me
i try to give them the in-depth answers
a year before i released them
to the general public
but this film i'm going to release
because i i'd like you to
consider the breath
because of all the things i've already
spoken about the arts the different
ways in
which they all
have a name
but it all means
that you should use the breath
efficiently
learning to use the breath is an art in
itself
we breathe in
and i find the most efficient and i
think others will agree
through the nose
and out through the mouth
try to make the out breath longer
it may seem a confusing thing because if
you take an
in-breath how can you make the out
breath longer
well it's called muscle control and the
mind is working at making it longer
perhaps there's some still left in the
lungs and if as the lungs expand become
more efficient the more air they will
hold and the more efficient
the control will be
so breathing in
i'm breathing out
so
[Music]
if you're going to use it in a martial
art or yoga when a passive state in
meditation it's very
well used
as you feel the breath gently touching
the sides of the nostrils as you're
starting to go down
deeper and deeper into your meditative
state
so you see
we need the breath
in many things
and for the normal 24 7 your body will
regulate how much you need
if you over exercise or demand too much
going up a hill or something this could
call upon you needing more breath
if you haven't learned to be efficient
with your breath
then it's going to be harder for you to
recover
if you learn how to be efficient with
your breath
then it's fuel that you need to make the
body recuperate quicker
slow the heart rate down
faster the whole
body the blood
is better purified
it appears that it's better to hold the
breath
but not
with puffed out cheeks
but to take in the breath and hold it
because the oxygen you're taking in
will
need to be filtered to go into the blood
system and the oxygen balance
in the blood
needs to be balanced correctly
and to be more efficient
if you just
you get dizzy and the body gets
very little value
and your whole being
is disorientated because you will say
hang on a minute i need to just get
gather myself because i've
i've
been breathing erratically
so it has to be done
with the right quantity
and the
efficiency to replenish but to
improve
your well-being
once you know this
you can take it like
an
enjoyable item
to take into your body
for the benefit to benefit your body
if you like what you're hearing
then
why not
the link below
underneath you can see it pop up where
it says my patreon site
go to the patreon site perhaps become a
member you don't have to it's not a tied
in thing for a lifetime
you can take it on a monthly basis
there's no demand when you've had enough
or you've had your film or didn't find
it interesting
you can just switch off
it's from as lit as five pounds a month
for the basic films if you want to go
even further wherever you are in the
world we can do zoom one to ones i can
watch your progress and your development
you can ask any questions you wish
and we can
[Music]
study together and let me give you my 50
years of
knowledge and understanding
in all the aspects that i'm talked about
aikido yoga tai chi meditation
it just builds and goes on so thank you
for listening and i hope you have found
this of interest